y a-t-il de l'eau sur Mars oui c'est pas
du tout un scoop mais la vraie question
que tout le monde se pose c'est quel
goût est là cette figurez-vous que grâce
à norvpn j'ai pu envoyer ma sœur jumelle
morte sur place elle est tend duplex
avec nous Fiona où es-tu en ce moment
que vois-tu autour de toi
merci pour ce reportage merci au plus
près de l'action le temps que tu as
marcies on va se préparer à te
téléguider sur place et pour ça on doit
savoir où il y a de l'eau sur Mars et
sous quelle forme croyez moi on sera pas
trop deux alors j'appelle mon FAF de
l'astronomie préféré le regretter point
Genius pH merci bonjour d'être avec nous
qu'est-ce que je fous là moi
messieurs dames et surtout mesdames
salut mais c'était pH que je t'inquiète
et nous on est vendu en pack moi tu as
qu'à me considérer comme l'échantillon
gratuit et d'ailleurs si tu veux
m'essayer c'est pas un problème ou je
sens que ma monétisation va pas s'en
relever de tout ça comme Philippe
Croizon ah non non ça c'est Samuel Paty
donc mars l'eau ou et dans quel étagère
alors déjà ma connaissance on n'a pas
vraiment trouvé de liquide à la surface
de Mars sauf là mais ça compte pas
vraiment c'est physiquement impossible
d'avoir de l'eau liquide en surface
aujourd'hui l'atmosphère martienne est
tellement pénible la pression
atmosphérique qui est si faible que
l'eau solide se sublime directement ça
fait glace vapeur et vapeur glace sans
passer par la gaz liquide sans passer
par la case liquide
je crois que Fiona vient de toucher une
rigolith et oui la voilà qui tente de
goûter l'air oui effectivement oui il y
a de la vapeur d'eau dans le peu d'air
qui flotte sur Mars mais pas beaucoup on
est sur 003% c'est quasi homéopathique
l'atmosphère martienne est 100 fois
moins humide que la nôtre comment il y
en a qui c'est une nous dire
mais je sais pas d'où il vient moi ce
goût acide aigle qui picote la langue
peut-être juste que tu as vu pH et ça
donne des remontées acides
l'atmosphère marcher dans les composés à
96% c'est hyper toxique pour nous
heureusement qu'elle a déjà morte sinon
ça l'aurait achevé bon ok l'atmosphère
pas idéal pour goûter l'eau continuons
Fiona est-ce que tu oui tu as raison
l'eau se cache aussi dans certains
minéraux comme les argiles sur lesquels
tu te situes car voyez-vous au départ
sur Mars on a une roche volcanique du
basalte mais au contact de l'eau ou de
certains gaz atmosphériques le basalte
va se faire altérer la mouille ça nous
crée toute une ribambelle des minéraux
dont certains vont piéger l'eau en leur
sens et des minéraux hydratés c'est
comme ça qu'on obtient notamment des
argiles c'est feuillets microscopiques
entre lesquels circulent des molécules
comme l'eau un mille-feuille interdit
notre eau est donc aussi là retenue
prisonnière à l'intérieur même de
certains cailloux martiens c'est la
Florence aubna géologie et si on veut
goûter cette eau l'éternel conclusion
s'impose
qu'est-ce que je fous là moi déjà alors
Fiona ça dégustation elles ont quel goût
ces argiles là un goût salé oui pourquoi
pas je continue à penser que la vue de
pH influence mais continue en route on
t'a envoyé le point GPS de la prochaine
destination c'est mal joué
Fiona tout va bien
faut bouger là
peut-être qu'elle est bien ici peut-être
que les morts ou elle a encore un truc
que nous montrer d'ailleurs moi aussi
j'ai un petit truc à vous montrer il y a
aussi de l'eau sous le sol martien c'est
la forme des sols gelés l'équivalent de
nos permafrost mergélisol en bon
français sauf qu'on y retrouve pas les
mammouths dans ce la cette glace cachée
ce sera un gros réservoir en plus
peut-être même le plus gros de la
planète on pense plus de 5 millions de
kilomètres cubes en tout et heureusement
qu'elle est cachée cette glace la fine
couche de cailloux qui la recouvre c'est
tout ce qui l'empêche de se faire
sublimer la tronche par les rayons du
soleil ah ça y est tu décides à
participer
[Musique]
et ouais donc il y en a des choses en
soustragolite il y aura même des lacs
gelés au milieu de cratère et des
glaciers bon faut les deviner sous la
couche de poussière mais il y a certains
indices qui n'échappent pas à l'oeil à
viséologues regardez-moi cette langue
glaciaire et c'est Morel là c'est de la
bouillabaisse pour les papilles une
moraine c'est une bande de cailloux qui
s'est fait racler par un glacier et qui
surfe devant lui ou sur les côtés au fur
et à mesure de son avancée et quand le
géant blanc se retire ça parle de moi ça
laisse ces petits tas de cailloux tous
bien alignés
aujourd'hui disparus et des glaciers
actuels je voudrais pas vous interrompre
mais Fiona elle bouge pas du tout depuis
tout à l'heure elle va bien peut-être
qu'elle arrive pas à gratter le sol pour
atteindre la glace là elle a l'air de
galérer non bon
[Musique]
c'est pas grave Fiona si tu nous entends
tu peux aller tout de suite au Pôle Nord
c'est plus important on se rejoint
là-bas et oui Jamel car sur Mars comme
sur terre il y a beaucoup de glace au
niveau des pôles et comme chez le volume
des calottes polaires va varier en
fonction de la saison mais sur Mars
c'est un peu plus rigolo comme phénomène
parce qu'il y a pas que de la glace
d'eau il y a aussi de la glace et du
carbone que de la glace de carbone et
bien oui je m'explique en hiver au pôle
c'est la nuit tous les jours et ça
caille sec jusqu'à -125 degrés ce qui
fait qu'environ le tiers du CO2 de
l'atmosphère martienne se condense pour
donner de la glace carbonique du CO2 à
l'état solide le tiers c'est pas rien vu
que rappelez-vous 96% de l'atmosphère
martienne c'est du CO2 et donc c'est de
la glace carbonique se mélangent au
calottes polaires et augmente leur
volume d'un à deux mètres d'épaisseur
quand même pour l'anecdote je suis né en
89 ce grand revenu ménage d'hiver à deux
conséquences d'une part ça fait diminuer
la pression atmosphérique au niveau du
sol vu qu'il y a beaucoup moins de
molécules dans l'air oui vous avez bien
entendu sur Mars la pression
atmosphérique n'est pas la même en été
et en hiver je trouve ça fou et d'autre
part ça va même jusqu'à modifier un tout
petit peu le champ gravitationnel de
mars en changeant la distribution des
masses à se surface si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur le champ de gravité les
géoïdes tout ça c'est votre jour de
chance j'ai fait une vidéo là dessus
[Musique]
donc voilà pour l'hiver en été il fait
un peu plus chaud les calottes sont
cuites la glace carbonique se sublime et
rejoint l'atmosphère la calotte polaire
n'est plus que de la glace d'eau au Pôle
Nord parce que au pôle Sud il fait assez
froid même en été pour qu'il reste
toujours un petit mélange des deux ce
qui est assez cool c'est que ces
changements saisonniers créent tout un
cycle de l'eau sur la planète rouge ça
fait même être du givre autour des pôles
et des Cyrus dans le ciel voilà qui vous
fait une belle jambe je confirme elle
est douce et soyeuse grâce à nordvpn
que tu me fais faire là vous voyez des
images des deux calottes prise en été en
volume elle contient deux un peu moins
d'eau que le Groenland à titre de
comparaison deux fois moins chacune du
coup j'ai pas compris la veine non on
peut pas forcer les vulgarisateurs avoir
du talon t'inquiète ma poule je prends
le relais un détail cool sur ces
calottes si on regarde bien on voit des
dessins en forme de spirale à leur
surface c'est des ravins creusés par les
vents qui ont dévalé la pente du glacier
on appelle ça des ventes katabatiques
l'air directement au-dessus de la
calotte se refroidit du coup il devient
plus dense ceux qui
ont pas la bonne police j'arrive pas à
lire et c'est la faute de la police tout
ça bien sûr l'air directement au-dessus
de la glace se refroidit du coup il
devient plus dense que ce qu'il y a
autour et va naturellement dévaler la
pente sous l'effet de la gravité du vent
dont les vidéos de Valentine sont
remplies et alors pourquoi les spirales
et bah ça c'est à cause de la force de
Coriolis Patrick de Coriolis vous savez
cette force là qui est due à la rotation
de la planète et qui fait vriller les
ouragans sur Terre par exemple et bah là
cette force de corioliste donne un petit
spin hanovant catabatique et au lieu de
descendre tout droit il dessine des
spirales en d'autres termes c'est
spirale matérialise la force de Coriolis
d'ailleurs on y retrouve tout de suite
notre envoyé spatial en direct du Pôle
Nord pour qu'elle nous y goûte le
bardage
du sommet
ou la tête ça a pas l'air très bon ce
que tu manges là
ça croustille tu dis ah mais c'est
normal ça parce que la glace elle est
pas propre elle est pleine de poussière
et cailloux cette culotte polaire en
fait c'est une accumulation de couches
de glace et de poussière du haut tempête
de sable qui agitent régulièrement la
surface de Martial ce coup-là c'est un
tiramisu interdit un tiramisu de
kilomètres d'épaisseur faut avoir faim
d'ailleurs les chercheurs s'y
intéressent pas mal pour étudier le
climat un peu comme on lit les cernes du
bois là notamment grâce
notamment aux imagesurs embarqués sur
les sons ils regardent ses dépôts en
couche successives pour reconstituer le
climat martien sur plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'années oui il y a des
changements climatiques sur Mars aussi
et non ce coup-là ça n'a rien à rater
Taylor Swift mais plutôt avec
l'inclinaison notamment de l'axe de
rotation de la planète et ça ça influe
sur la manière dont l'astre reçoit les
rayons du soleil et donc sur le climat
ce qui est aussi valable sur terre entre
parenthèses on met du coup la glace du
Pôle Nord martien c'est de l'eau qui
pique à cause de la glace carbonique et
qui croque sous la dent à cause de la
poussière
je vous laisse les reines de la chaîne
j'en ai pas pour longtemps
ah bah tiens c'est super je vais en
profiter pour vous faire un petit
PowerPoint sur Vierzon son charme ses
atouts ses coups de coeur il faut pas
déconner quand même on va pas torpiller
sa chaîne à des fous de pouvoir la
torpiller et il y a quand même un truc
qui vous a dit qui me paraît un peu
bizarre comme quoi que il y aurait soit
dix ans pas d'eau liquide sur Marseille
alors il y a pas d'océan peut-être mais
d'une on pense qu'il y en a déjà eu et
de deux il y a quand même quelques
indices qui montrent qu'il y aurait
quand même peut-être de l'eau sur Mars
sauf que on l'a juste pas encore détecté
pareil pour le cerveau de pH il y a
quelques indices qui montrent qu'ils
pourraient y avoir un peu d'intelligence
mais on n'a pas encore détecté non plus
euh non c'est chiant bon viens on les
mannequin franc d'un SMR plutôt assez
tentant c'est tentant mais non les
indices tu aurais peut-être de l'eau sur
Mars alors premièrement il y a mars
reconnaissant sur 8 heures qui a détecté
des structures qui ressembleraient un
peu à des dégoulinettes de liquide et
qui se passe que en été on les appelle
les écoulements saisonniers mesdames sur
les Pancho de mars mars c'est le surnom
de ma femme ah oui ok je comprends mieux
pourquoi tu voulais parler de ça et dans
ces chenaux ils auraient trouvé des
traces de Saumur des saumons tout à fait
des saumures de l'eau liquide sur qui
pourrait en théorie persister quelques
heures à la surface de Mars avant de
s'évaporer c'est même curiosity qui a
aidé à les détecter ces machins elle
sait pas ce qu'il est il était curieux
il fait preuve de curiosité
tu fais tellement pas confiance que des
mères comme ça je suis sûr que tu allais
mettre dans ta vidéo mais je croyais que
c'était impossible d'avoir de l'eau
liquide à la surface de Mars oui mais là
c'est de l'eau salée ça modifie la
physique du machin ça baisse son point
de congélation ce qui permet de fondre
la glace pour obtenir de l'eau liquide
métastable au lieu d'être solide elle
est liquide grâce au sel c'est un peu
comme quand on selle les routes en hiver
ben c'est pour que l'eau liquide se
transforme pas en eau liquides enfin en
op c'est pour que ça fasse pas une
patinoire c'est pour qu'on glisse pas
compris alors on n'est pas sûr qu'il y a
un lien entre ces saumurs et puis les
traces de dégoulinat de dont on parlait
mais si c'est le cas il en faudrait
quand même une sacrée quantité assez
pour pouvoir dévaler une bande de
parfois 100 mètres après tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord là-dessus moi par
exemple je suis pas d'accord c'est
s'écoulement pour être dû à un coulis de
CO2 liquide et pas d'eau ou alors c'est
juste des éboulements sans cueiller du
liquide et impliqué dans l'affaire donc
c'est pas sûr mais c'est pas sûr non
plus ouais c'est pas beaucoup plus clair
qu'avant faut vraiment que je vous
apprenne votre métier c'est plus
possible un autre truc c'est que tu peux
c'est c'est pour vous avertir que votre
période d'essai est terminée du coup là
je garantis plus rien
je suis passé des trucs bizarres [ __ ]
un échantillon gratuit donc je disais un
autre truc cool en 2020 on a découvert
Paris imagerie radar des anomalies
prennent du Pôle Sud qui pourrait faire
penser à des lacs d'eau salée sous une
bonne couche de glace sauf que ça fait
encore des bas parce que ça se trouve
c'est pas du tout ça mais bon on est
d'accord l'eau liquide et pas proprement
parler à la surface de Mars mais
peut-être qu'elle serait quand même là
sur Mars ou sous mars et en plus ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que si on a là
mais il y a peut-être encore ailleurs
sauf que ça on le sait pas encore tu
sais plutôt d'attendre l'émission que
les chercheurs des pires que les
résultats tout ça il suffit de poser la
question à notre correspondre en région
Fiona toi qui a parcouru la planète tu
en as croisé le liquide
super merci Fiona voilà encore un
mystère de Résolu Harry là vraiment je
me coucherai moins con donc voilà ça y
est je lance mon produit dérivé j'ai
fabriqué ma propre eau martienne c'est
un mélange d'un peu tout ce qui a pu
goûterionna
des cristaux de glace des sels minéraux
et un soupçon de poussière enrichie au
CO2 de la source
la fontaine martienne
s'accroustille
précommander dès aujourd'hui sur notre
site internet
c'était peut-être une planète bleue
enfin il y a pas mal de traces qui vont
dans ce sens en tout cas rien que la
présence de minéraux hydrater comme nos
argiles au début ben c'est sans doute un
signe qui a eu l'eau liquide à un moment
en l'occurrence il y a 3 milliards et
demi d'années avant le Père Fouras puis
aussi toutes ces structures qui sur
terre se forment grâce à l'eau des
canyons des deltas des lacs à séchés
qu'on trouve sur Mars on se rend compte
qu'il y aurait peut-être eu un océan qui
couvrait plus du tiers de la surface de
la planète il y a montré à 3 milliards
et demi d'années donc à peu près quand
tes argiles sont apparus ça reste une
hypothèse mais effectivement ça serait
un peu cool mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé pour qu'on passe d'une majestueuse
planète bleue à une espèce de déchet
tout sec et tout rouge comme pH en été
est-ce que les petits hommes verts
étaient comme nous ils ont cramé leur
planète ils prenaient leur jet privé
pour aller chercher le pain manger de la
viande à tous les repas et participer
aux event pour se donner bonne
conscience ben non justement le problème
sur Mars c'est pas qu'il y a eu trop de
CO2 c'est qu'il y en avait plus assez la
planète rouge est plus petite que la
nôtre elle s'est donc fatigué plus vite
son activité volcanique c'est peu à peu
réduite ces volcans ont craché de moins
en moins de CO2 dans l'atmosphère et
comme c'est le principal constituant de
l'air sur Mars l'atmosphère c'est tout
simplement évaporé petit à petit comme
mon ex la pression atmosphérique c'est
réduite et l'effet de serre aussi du
coup le climat s'est refroidi et les
conditions physiques ne permettait plus
à l'autre se maintenir à l'état liquide
sans doute qu'une majeure partie de
l'eau martienne c'est volatilisée dans
l'espace et le reste est resté coincé
dans ces différents réservoirs ces sols
son sous-sol ses glaciers et ses
calottes polaires ah il y a Fiona qui te
pose une question je crois
pourquoi on t'a envoyé là-haut ben c'est
pour connaître le goût de l'eau
martienne on l'a dit au début la vraie
question qui se cache derrière c'est
quand même d'une part est-ce que il y a
de l'eau dispo pour nous sur Mars auquel
cas elle nous fournirait les glaçons
pour le pastis si on montait une colonie
humaine là-bas ou bien nous permettrait
de faire le plein de flotte Ostende
avant d'aller explorer l'espace et
l'autre question certains peut
secondaire qu'on se pose c'est y a-t-il
ou y a-t-il eu de la vie là-bas oui
parce que si vous êtes pas remarqué sur
terre la vie était étroitement liée à la
présence d'eau alors on cherche un petit
peu le même genre de lieu qui serait
susceptible d'accueillir la vie ou alors
qu'il l'aurait accueilli par le passé et
là pour le coup c'est pas encore gagné
parce que même s'il y a de l'eau elle
est trop froide pour être accueillante
et puis même parfois beaucoup trop salé
un peu comme Valentine
juste pour le goût de l'eau
je remercie dans VPN d'être à nouveau le
partenaire particulier de cette chaîne
dans ma vie il y a vraiment eu un avant
et un après nordvpn avant j'étais
maintenant j'existe nordvpn m'a vraiment
apporté beaucoup d'argent de sécurité
dans mes transactions en ligne plein
plein de sécurité nordvpn c'est plus
qu'un moyen de chiffrer mes données pour
me permettre de surfer sur le net en
toute sécurité c'est un état d'esprit
c'est une philosophie d'ailleurs comme
disait Bergson et BHL avant lui je rêve
d'un VPN qui met à l'abri à la fois la
daronne et mes données Internet derrière
un tunnel de chiffrement dernière
génération nordvpn ne savait pas que
c'était impossible alors ils l'ont fait
alors ils l'ont fait
en nous permettant de masquer notre
adresse IP et nous empêche de nous faire
traquer par autrui et s'engage aussi à
ne pas collecter ni partager nos données
personnelles en plus c'est très facile à
utiliser en un clic on est protégé et ce
sur jusqu'à 6 appareils simultanément de
cela Bergson aux États peine rêvé dans
son prolégomène à toutes métaphysiques
futures qui pourra se présenter comme
science vous aussi participer à la
marche du progrès protégez-vous lors de
vos promenades sur le net et rendez les
plus grands philosophes d'hier fiers de
vous vous disposez de 30 jours
satisfaits ou remboursés et grâce à mon
lien nordvpn.com/ sciences de comptoir à
retrouver un description profitez de
quatre mois offerts sur tout abonnement
de 2 ans 4 mois c'est justement le temps
qu'il a fallu à schopenhower pour voir
s'écouler 122 jours coïncidence alors
n'attendez plus précipitez-vous sur
nordvpn.com/s
j'espère que vous avez appris deux trois
trucs aujourd'hui si j'avais jamais
voulu être chercheur un jour
je pense que mon si mal si j'avais voulu
être chercheur c'est un des domaines qui
m'aurait un petit peu intéressé sauf que
flemme je trouve ça hyper cool quand
même de pouvoir faire les géologie sur
une autre planète déjà que sur terre
c'est compliqué et pas toujours très
accessible mais là c'est carrément se
mettre plein de bâtons dans les roues il
y a pas moyen de prendre la prochaine
navette pour aller taper sur un petit
camion et vous dira je vous avais dit
c'est l'argile c'est pas possible ça
passe forcément par de l'observation à
distance de la comparaison avec ce qu'on
connaît sur terre du coup bah faut bien
connaître ce qu'il y a sur terre aussi
vous passez par des instruments
compliqués de l'imagerie des mesures de
permittivité que j'ai toujours rien
compris mais en plus ça dépend de son de
Rover du coup il y a plein de corps de
métiers qui sont appliqués il faut
qu'ils puissent survivre à l'espace au
transport et tout bref c'est une grande
aventure humaine
[Musique]
et je suis ravie que pour cette grande
aventure le point Genius est 12 par sac
me fait l'honneur de participer à cet
épisode un peu spécial je remercie pour
leur enthousiasme et leur bon goût si
vous les connaissez pas n'allez pas
avoir leur chaîne et préserver votre
innocence
[Musique]
même un petit dépôt là je sais pas si
vous voyez comme le bon vin
[Musique]
pourquoi Yann il a plus de textes que
moi mais ça se voit tellement que tu es
amoureuse de Yann ah comment ça me
dégoûte quoi après tout ce qu'on a vécu